es ist das wohl verblüffendste
experiment der physik es geht um das so
genannte doppel spalt experiment je
nachdem wie es aufgebaut wird sind die
teilchen die durch zwei spalten fliegen
teilchen oder eben wellen paradox ein
neuartiger versuchsaufbau offenbart
jetzt dass die herkunft des photons also
das licht zeichens darüber bestimmt zu
welchen anteilen an proton teilchen oder
eben welleneigenschaften verein quanten
anwendungen wie beispielsweise der
quantencomputer könnten von dieser
spektakulären erkenntnis profitieren
klick substanzen future gibt es dreimal
pro woche spannendes videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen was ist nicht
wirklich teilchen oder wellen ein
dilemma der physik ein österreichischer
physiker hatte das mal so formuliert
montag mittwoch und freitag ist das
licht eine welle dienstag donnerstag und
samstag ist es ein teilchen und am
sonntag gutes es steht es gibt
experimente in den licht und elektronen
strahlung er mit dem teilchen modell
erklärt werden können bei anderen
experimenten passt dass wellen modell
besser albert einstein hatte vor rund
100 jahren gesagt dass er den rest
seines lebens darüber nachdenken wird
was licht ist und bis heute gehört der
welle teilchen dualismus zu einem der
ungelösten rätsel der quanten
wissenschaft dabei ist sie es die uns so
beispiellose technologien ermöglicht wie
etwa quantencomputer oder
quantenkommunikation das quanten
internet der traum vieler
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit damit ließen sich perfekt
abhörsichere nachrichten versenden und
es sind bei weitem nicht nur forschende
die dieses visionäre internet herbei
sehen sondern natürlich auch regierung
und das militär die ein großes interesse
haben alle informationen
hundertprozentig abzusichern aber auch
unternehmen wie banken oder
versicherungen wollen ihre verträge und
transaktionen geheim halten dazu kommt
möglicherweise sind die ersten
quantencomputer schon in naher zukunft
in der lage die verschlüsselungen die
derzeit noch verwendet werden zu knacken
das quanten internet könnte hier abhilfe
schaffen doch nicht nur das konnten
computer könnten viele weitere komplexe
probleme lösen in der
medikamentenforschung für berechnung in
der logistik der finanzwirtschaft bei
künstlicher intelligenz oder
datensicherheit ein quanten internet
also ein netzwerk über das gespeicherte
informationen über große entfernungen
ausgetauscht werden könnte sogar eine
neue ära der kommunikation anleiten doch
das muss man sich mal vorstellen selbst
heutzutage ein jahrhundert nach den
anfängen der trachten mechanik haben
physikerinnen und physiker noch immer
nicht den durchblick grundlegende
experimentelle erkenntnisse in diesem
zusammenhang zu interpretieren doch
jetzt ist es zwei kanten forschern aus
südkorea gelungen den welle teilchen
dualismus erstmals im experiment zu
bestätigen ihr neuartiger versuchsaufbau
offenbart gleich zwei super spannende
erkenntnisse alle wichtigen infos dazu
gibt es jetzt hier bei pixum science in
future der berühmte isaac newton er
hatte sich nicht als teilchen
vorgestellt den da besteht licht also
aus winzigen teilchen die newton selbst
korpus köln genannt hat mit diesem
modell können die gradlinige licht
ausbreitung und reflektionen erklärt
werden demnach werden die kosten von den
leuchtenden körper mit großer
geschwindigkeit in alle richtungen aus
geschleudert und bewegen sich im leeren
raum gradlinig probleme bekommt newtons
vorstellung von nicht als teilchen wenn
man beugung und interferenz erklären
möchte das ist nicht möglich und so trat
der englische physiker thomas lang auf
die bühne um die vorstellung des großen
ensembles
zu werfen 1803 demonstrierte er der
royal society in london den wohl
berühmtesten laborversuch aller zeiten
das doppel spalt experiment das hat er
entwickelt um die wellenförmigen natur
des lichts zu beweisen thomas young war
augenarzt und der erste wissenschaftler
der mit einem doppel spalt experimente
durchführte es ging hierbei um licht und
die muster aus dunklen und hellen
bereichen die hinter dem doppelstart
entstehen lichtwellen die von jedem der
beiden spalte ausgehen überlagern sich
hier und verstärken bzw schwächen sich
gegenseitig ab ein interferenzmuster
entsteht wie eben bei wellen knapp 160
jahre später 1959 hatte der tübinger
doktorand klaus jensen dieses experiment
dann nicht mit licht sondern mit
elektronen ausgeführt was hier also
passiert ein elektronen wird auf zwei
zusammenlebende schlitz gefeuert was
dann passiert ist wirklich verblüffend
denn das elektron schlüpft quasi durch
beide schlitze gleichzeitig der
klassischen ansicht weise handelt sie
sich bei elektronen ja aber um teilchen
mit einer bestimmten masse und einem
zugehörigen ort dort das doppel spalt
experiment zeigt dass auch in diesem
fall überlagerung musste entstehen die
für wellen charakteristisch sind das
fazit dass janssen zog auch elektronen
können sich wie wählen verhalten
manchmal wird das doppel spalt
experiment sogar als jahrhundert
experiment bezeichnet denn es zeigt eine
sache ganz besonders gut die welt im
kleinen funktioniert nach komplett
anderen gesetzmäßigkeiten als wir es aus
unserem alltag kennen das wird durch
eine weitere beobachtung verstärkt wenn
man nämlich überprüft durch welche
öffnungen die einzelnen elektronen
fliegen dann ist das überlagerung muster
von jetzt auf gleich wie vom erdboden
verschluckt hinter dem doppel spalt sind
die beiden spalte als lichtprojektion zu
sehen wo das interferenzmuster ist
verschwunden das experiment wurde in der
vergangenen zeit vielfach
weiterentwickelt und
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit haben beispielsweise einzelne
photonen oder die bausteine
herkömmlicher materie wie elektronen und
neutronen durch den doppel spalt
geschickt und sogar moleküle also ganze
strukturen von atomen die ergebnisse
sind spektakulär und rätselhaft zugleich
sie werfen tatsächlich neue grundlegende
fragen über die natur der realität auf
auch ein südkoreanisches forschungsteam
hat sich intensiv mit dem doppel spalt
experiment beschäftigt die beiden
konnten wissenschaftler haben einen
neuartigen versuchsaufbau entwickelt bei
der die so genannte quellen reinheit
sehr genau zu steuern ist das
autorenteam konnte also ganz genau
bestimmen mit welcher wahrscheinlichkeit
die photonen aus dem einen oder dem
anderen kristall kommen dieser neuartige
versuchsaufbau führt zu einer super
spannenden erkenntnis demnach ist die
herkunft nämlich entscheidend zu welchen
anteilen ein photon über teilchen oder
welleneigenschaften verfügt wo für ihren
versuch haben die beiden konnten
wissenschaftler zwei kristalle aus
silizium leopard genutzt die photonen
die bei diesem versuch genauer ins
visier genommen wurden stammen entweder
aus dem einen oder aus dem anderen die
entscheidende neuerung bei diesem
experiment die quellen reinheit ist von
den fachleuten sehr genau zu steuern
heißt also das autorenteam konnte sehr
genau einstellen mit welchen
wahrscheinlichkeiten die photonen aus
dem einen oder dem anderen kristall
stammen und somit auch die oft sie durch
welchen spalt fliegen die konnten
forscher konnten also einstellen ob
beide kristalle als quelle gleich
wahrscheinlich sind oder ob einer von
beiden sehr viel wahrscheinlicher
der ursprung der photonen ist bei
lithium ion bad handelt es sich um einen
transparenten kristallinen feststoff der
so nicht in der natur vorkommt sondern
aus einer schmelze gezogen wird und es
gibt eine besondere eigenschaft wird
solch ein kristall nämlich mit einem
laser bestrahlt sendet er photonen aus
die verschränkt sind es sind
lichtteilchen deren quanteneigenschaften
zusammenhängen und die einen gemeinsamen
quantenzustand teilen manipuliere ich
dass eine teilchen geschieht das auch
mit dem anderen teilchen egal wo es sich
im universum befindet in ihrem
experiment maßen die beiden konnten
wissenschaftler also dann jedesmal
prinzipiell nach ob sich bei meinen der
teilchen oder beim anderen der wellen
charakter offenbarte die intensität des
interferenzmuster das in einem
interferometer gilt als maß für den
wellen charakter wenn der ort sich
prinzipiell messen lässt offenbart dies
den teilchen charakter das ergebnis ist
spektakulär und war sogar für die beiden
wissenschaftler selbst eine große
überraschung demnach scheint die
herkunft darüber zu bestimmen für
welchen anteilen an photon wellen und
teilchen eigenschaften vereint heißt
also die experimentelle bestätigung des
grundprinzips der welle teilchen
dualität ist damit erstmals gelungen
gleich zwei wichtige und spannende
erkenntnisse resultieren aus diesem
experiment zum einen ist nun klar dass
der welle teilchen dualismus tatsächlich
von der quellen reinheit abhängt das war
vorher bereits in der theorie
vorhergesagt worden zum anderen zeigt
der neuartige versuchsaufbau dass die
teilchen welleneigenschaften über
miteinander verschränkte teilchen
erfasst werden können der welle teilchen
dualismus kann somit auch mit der
quantenverschränkung verknüpft werden
heißt also im prinzip es ist gar kein
wirklicher dualismus sondern es sind
zwei eigenschaften eines teilchens die
in anteilen bestehen und in diesem
experiment konnten diese bestimmt werden
es kommt damit eine zusätzliche
kontrolle über die eigenschaften von
kanten objekten erlangt werden die
beiden konnten forscher hoffen dass
diese erkenntnisse dabei helfen können
weitere anwendungen rund um den
quantencomputer zu entwickeln das ist
wirklich absolut bahn brechen die größte
maschine der welt gigantischer plan des
herrn lhc nachfolger der superlative
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren super
spannendes video unter dem ist übrigens
auch einen abo button gibt wie hier
unter dem video abonnieren macht
übrigens schlau und kostet nichts nur
einen einzigen klick bis dann bleibt
dran